hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the course of
his work on fate where Cicero is
discussing whether everything is in fact
determined or whether we have some
measure of freedom of choice or of the
will he discusses something that has
been called by convention the idle
argument it already had a name by the
time that Cicero encounters it both in
Greek and in Latin in Greek it is the
Argos logos and in Cicero's Latin it is
the Ignacio and when we say argument
here you don't necessarily want to think
of something in syllogistic form but
think of a line of argumentation really
having to do with our practical
reasoning about what we ought to do or
what we ought not to do and it's
interesting if you put it that way
because it's really saying is its
conclusion don't do anything because
nothing that you do makes any difference
or if you want the opposite of that do
whatever you want because nothing you do
makes any difference and how do we get
there so Cicero is going to give us a
formulation of this that has to do with
somebody being sick and the question is
should they call for the doctor or
now and notice that both sides of the
argument begin with the same if-then
statement if it is faded and then
something follows after that then and
then something follows after that so
what are the two sides if it's faded for
you to recover from this illness then
you will recover from the illness
whether you bring in a doctor or not and
you could expand this to other things
whether you consult WebMD whether you
lay in bed all day or whether you go out
drinking no matter what you do if you're
fated to recover from that illness you
will recover from that illness on the
other hand the statement runs if it's
fated for you to not recover from that
illness then you won't recover from that
illness and that holds whether you bring
in a doctor or don't bring in a doctor
we could extend this to other things as
well
again maybe you bring in a doctor but
you don't listen to the doctor's advice
we could go on and on and on and you
could say this about other things to
think about whether you're going to find
the person who is the ideal mate for you
if you're going to find that person it
doesn't matter whether you go out on
dates or not you will find that person
if it's faded and if it's faded that you
won't find that person then it doesn't
matter how many dates you go on you'll
never find that person and so what is
the conclusion of this do whatever you
want don't do anything it doesn't matter
what you do because it's already faded
that it's going to go one way or another
so nothing that you as a human agent can
do within the situation will actually
make any contribution to a different
outcome
so given most people's propensity
towards the sort of laziness and
indolence Cicero actually says you can
not only call this the Ignazio but also
the
there's meaning just gonna sit there
doing nothing this is an argument for
doing nothing an argument for as we
called it fatalism and people have this
sort of view about all sorts of things
in their life
Cicero goes on to note another feature
of this you can take the word fate out
of it altogether if you wanted to you
could say for for example if the
statement you will recover from that
illness has been true from all eternity
you'll recover whether you call in a
doctor or do not similarly if the
statement you will recover from that
illness has been false from all eternity
you will not recover whether you call it
a doctor or not and the conclusion will
still be the same so you could take fate
out and you could substitute something
else in there like destiny or necessity
whatever you like you can even put God
in there if God has predetermined from
all time that you will be a good person
then you don't have to do anything
you're gonna be a good person or if God
is predetermined from all time that you
will marry this person and have 16
children 14 of which will die and two of
which will go on and do this and that
there's nothing you can do about it it's
just going to happen the way that it
does you're just gonna go along with the
flow now there are some people who do
view things this way in a very
fatalistic manner Cicero is not one of
them and cruciferous the great stoic
philosopher was not one of them either
if you want to attack this argument
though you have to make some sort of
distinction and then you have to come to
a counter conclusion about it you can't
just say well it's bunk it's no good it
is a bad argument but we need to know
why that's the case
and so Cicero refers us here to
cruciferous who is going to make a very
important distinction saying that
there's actually two different classes
or types of what we can translate as
facts or if you like states of affairs
race is the Latin for it so in labels in
states of affairs or in facts there are
there are two types one of which is
simple simply Kia all right
straightforward we don't have to worry
about the translation there the other of
which we translate as complex Co pelota
we're putting things together Pat was
the word we get copulate from where you
know human beings come together and
engage in a certain sort of Congress a
little bit later he's gonna call those
con destined it he's he's creating a new
word there Cohn fought a lot Fatalis in
Latin and how does this help us well
let's look at some examples of what he
means by simple and complex facts Cicero
tells us that an instance of a simple
fact is Socrates will die at a given
date Socrates will die tomorrow Socrates
will die three weeks from now whatever
it happens to be I will in walking
across the street no actually that would
be a complex one but I will fall down
the stairs later today and anything
along those lines is going to be simple
he says in this case whether he does
some action or does not do it the day of
his death has been determined he's gonna
die all right
it doesn't matter whether Socrates
watches his cholesterol or goes and
exercises or anything like that he's
gonna die and we can think of some other
things along those lines now what would
be examples of complex facts here he's
drawing on the Oedipus story very
familiar to people in ancient Greece
perhaps not quite as familiar to us so
let me tell you a very thumbnail sketch
of it Oedipus is a young child about
whom there's a prophecy that he's going
to kill his father Mary his mother and
this prophecy follows him he actually
leaves his adopted mother and father so
that it won't come true and encounters
his father ends up killing him without
recognizing him as his biological father
Mary's his biological mother
has four children and then there's a
curse on the land the the Prophet
finally reveals to Oedipus that he has
committed this terrible sin of incest
and patricide and it goes downhill even
further from there so that's providing
us with a instance for this complex fact
and what is the complex fact it's faded
he says if it's fated that Laius will
have a son Oedipus it will not be
possible for the words whether layest
mates with a woman or does not in order
to have a son Oedipus of course he's got
to have sex with a woman I mean there's
other ways around it you could say well
what about a petri dish or all sorts of
other things yes but then you're just
substituting some other provided that he
does this phrase that brings these
things together that that brings simple
facts together into a complex so he says
the matter is complex and con destined
it he gives that name to it because he
thinks it's fated both that Laius will
lie with a wife and that he will beget
Oedipus by her he uses another example
of this famous wrestler Milo he says
Milo will wrestle at olympia simple fact
or complex fact seems like a simple fact
but there's actually something that's
required there right Milo will wrestle
at olympia whether he has an opponent or
not no he's not going to wrestle without
an opponent so that is a complex fact
and we can look at the argos logos like
that cicero draws the the conclusion
here he says all arguments of that sort
can be refuted in the same way you will
recover whether you call in a doctor or
not is as he calls it captious kept
yas'm for calling in a doctor is just as
much faded as recovering so cruciferous
views all of those as cond estimate all
those as faded but we could go a little
bit further than Cicero's going
here and think about the implications if
you know that you know you've got an
illness and you say well it's faded that
if I you know I'm gonna die I'm gonna
die maybe the doctor is how you prevent
yourself from dying maybe that is one of
those other facts that needs to come
into it maybe you choosing now Cicero
would say you don't actually have a
choice that scizor cruciferous would say
it's it's destined already that you're
going to call the doctor
Cicero would say well you've got a
choice whether you call the doctor or
not right call the doctor
maybe you won't die if you don't call
the doctor probably you will die if it's
fated that you're going to die because
you don't call the doctor maybe not
having that medical advice and following
the treatment is in fact exactly why you
die it's one of the causes of you dying
just as Laius cannot and gender or beget
Oedipus without actually having sex with
with a woman if Leia says I'll have a
child no matter what I do
oh that's this idol argument really
doesn't have sex then there's no Oedipus
so the idol argument is really what we
call a sophism but it's one that has to
do with practical life and Cicero here
is concerned with combating a certain
kind of fatalism that would keep us from
doing anything or choosing anything
under the guise you could say of saying
that everything is already determined
ahead of time so we make no contribution
Cicero thinks we actually do make some
sort of contribution cruciferous thinks
that all these things are faded but we
have conjoint causes that that then wind
up in these complex states of affairs
you